welcome back everybody the young
super successful entrepreneur evan
carmichael is here to guide us through
any small business owners who may be
doing the wrong thing in terms of giving
a good appearance to make them appear
like they're a big successful
enterprise good morning good morning and
i said you look like a baby you're 27
years young
yeah but you've been at this for a while
yeah i had my first business when i was
19 years old it was a biotech software
company
it's amazing so it's been around for a
while yeah so you learned a lot of
things and it doesn't
it doesn't take a lot of time or cost a
lot of money to do it right right
absolutely absolutely the first thing
really is dressing for success so having
that professional look
so just because you work from home and
your pajamas half the day
it doesn't mean that your customers know
that about you so the image that you put
out there
really can make the impact and if you
make or break you know those big clients
for you yeah with the exception of hugh
hefner who pulls off the robe at all
times because that's just
you should be wearing the suit invest in
a couple of good suits and a couple of
different ties right
yeah it doesn't always have to be a suit
the rule of thumb really is dress
one step above what you think your
customer is going to be dressed as
so if your customer's coming in jeans
and a t-shirt then maybe you wear some
nice pants and a nice shirt
if they're coming in a pants and shirt
you may want to put a blazer on if
they're going to wear a blazer you wear
a suit so just based on your knowledge
with the customer and the same for women
i mean go for more tailored looks
based on what your absolute clientele is
okay and another thing you say is
offices if you don't have one you can
kind of sort of fake it and have a
pseudo
office yeah yeah if you don't have a an
office if you work from home
there's a lot of offices that you can
rent out for boardroom space so you can
have meetings downtown at different
offices
i did that with one of my first
companies and yeah we had an office down
at yonge king where i went down for
meetings so i could entertain clients
and bring to my office okay
but also you can even get meetings at
starbucks have a lot of informal
meetings at starbucks
uh at a nice downtown local so just make
it seem like you know what i need a
break i gotta get out of the office
that's it yeah i like it i want to get
out of the office i want to make it
casual
so why don't we just meet up with
starbucks i'll buy you a coffee so do
not have them in your home
den or kitchen or living room or
basement right yeah you really want to
create that professional
appeal okay very cool and receptionist
do you say hire people part time or is
it better off getting the automated
thing
what do you think doesn't mix there's a
lot of services you can get where
uh somebody will answer the phones for
you and they'll route it to your cell
phone or
or your own phone there are some
automated services and it does make you
look a little bit bigger and it's
really cheap to get it done um you can
hire people
part-time for reception services or for
other types of admin work
the first person i hired was for one
hour a day really and most people don't
think you can hire someone for only an
hour a day
but it was for a lot of admin work that
i just didn't want to do
and i hired somebody on for an hour a
day and now i could say i have a
part-time staffer and makes your company
bigger
so you've got the part-time staff your
part-time office when they can be coming
in for those meetings yeah
so you make it all look like it's it's
the legitimate bigger business than it
actually is
absolutely which is a great idea another
thing that's so important in terms of
aesthetics
is the cards that she hand out now what
are people doing wrong when it comes to
business cards
the first thing is necessary sorry we
should say this is done
this is a good example this is a good
example this is a company a local
company called toronto dance salsa
and they teach salsa classes in in the
gta
the key thing is you need to invest in
some marketing materials it's not like
before where you needed to have glossy
flyers and brochures
and spend tons of dollars doing it and
then if any one minor detail change you
have to throw everything out and start
all over again
with the business card you want to make
sure it looks professional so you don't
want to do those home
printed business cards it's a little no
it's a no-no okay with the perforated
edges
people don't take you seriously if you
have those types of business cards
and it doesn't cost too much money to
actually go out and get professional
design business cards
and you can do it online very cheaply as
well so this is a good example of a
business card and
the owner has received a lot of
compliments as a result it's a good
investment
as well you've got uh you've got some
examples of websites because of course
this is the way
in terms of getting new business and
getting yourself out there and
advertising
today so is this what we you would call
it a
a poor example or a good example of how
to create a website well this is this is
the poor example
it's kind of hard for you to see from
this angle but uh we wanted to look at
two websites one is a good example one
is a bad
and this is the poor one it's a company
out of texas want to
show an american company instead of
toronto and it's a company called mike
wagner dance
and mike wagner is a very accomplished
dancer and he's won a number of
different awards
but if you look at his website it's very
poorly designed where his pictures
is really hard to see the text colors
don't work
the pictures are again very small and
difficult to read
okay and his email address as well as an
aol
free email address which is another
no-no for
small business where you want to make
sure if you have your own domain name so
his is mike wagnerdance.com
to use your own domain name in your
email address as opposed to an aol or
hotmail or yahoo no hotmail no yahoo no
hotmail no yahoo use your own domain
name that looks a lot more professional
because
the big companies that you deal with the
representatives are always using their
own
domain name so right and incorporate
your business name go to likepartyguy64
at hotmail.com right right absolutely
more information go to
evancarmichael.com very useful tips
thank you so much
great thank you enjoy and continue
success